[Music]
as you know we recently had progressive
commentator david pakman on the show we
were delighted to have david on because
we wanted to have another good faith
conversation with someone on the
progressive left good faith to us means
we let our guests speak we challenge
politely and seek to balance areas where
we agree with errors where we disagree
during the interview it means that when
someone makes a good point we accept it
and when we can't agree we probe a bit
before moving on and finally it means
that we don't cherry pick bits of the
interviews to make our guests look bad
we don't misrepresent them and we don't
go into the conversation to destroy them
we go in to hear what they have to say
and the great thing about david is he
believes in good faith discussion as
well
previously on trigonometry
beautiful so are you guys open to a good
faith conversation about that absolutely
okay absolutely or does he
[Music]
after smearing us in good faith by
calling us right wing david then
proceeds by selecting a representative
clip of the interview
let's get now to my interview with the
right wing trigger nomitry let's pick it
up
oh i don't know we did democrat we did
bite administration
um
okay yeah let's pick it up where we were
and uh listen operations could have gone
better is that do you think that's
when trump was given trump
that that was a quagmire
eventually david finds the bit where he
genuinely shows me up to be
underprepared
um i i what i would say is i think some
progress was made in a very difficult
situation i don't claim that the
situation became
dramatically different and we are now
like way way towards a solution and also
i think i'd also consider it's not an
issue i know enough about to have a
proper discussion with you as well
that's fair let's let's we'll we can
table it on that on that basis
he's all about good faith so are we
which is why i will say he caught me out
not being able to back up what i said i
was right even many trump critics
admitted that he had made progress in
the middle east but not being able to
cite specifics is my bad well done to
david for catching me out in good faith
[Laughter]
we couldn't work out why david decided
to show such good faith
but then it came to us this is an
interview on the right wing channel
trigger nomentry
and it's getting flooded with comments
antagonizing me
so we've been brigading the video and
leaving like comically positive comments
david pakman is authentically these
comments are so positive from you guys
that to us they're up to our community
they're obviously a joke
in other words some of you didn't agree
with him and he got upset
he got so upset that he encouraged his
audience to leave fake comments on the
interview in good faith so i think i
think the comment bombs have probably uh
been been noticed at this point in time
now we would never selectively edit
something he said we'll show you what he
said in context instead
here they go like are you suggesting
that a lot of trump followers are stupid
and i'm like yeah that's
they were like
david can i uh in the spirit of a very
this is the best good faith but honest
conversation please can i feed back to
you what it sounds like you just said
from where i'm sitting yes which is
francis was saying to you there's a
large portion of the american public who
are so alienated by some of the rhetoric
on the left that they they went
to they had to resort to voting for
donald trump that's his argument and
what you said is no that that isn't
really the problem the problem is
americans are ill-educated and quite
stupid and full for for trump's
bombastic statements that's what it
sounds like did i hear you right it's a
combination of both
okay now here's one thing about it
sorry david just to finish this point
isn't that always the case though i mean
it's not like the public got massively
more stupid and ill-educated in the last
four years right or the last six years
so well
i don't know
apparently admitting that he thinks the
reason people disagree with him is that
they're stupid and uneducated is the
best bit he actually thinks that the
discord ranker and bitterness of the
last six years will be resolved by the
exact sort of sneering that got trump
elected in the first place when we
continue to challenge him on this
ironically he does a trump double damn
wouldn't wouldn't you accept that these
movements these right-wing populist
movements we also had this here in the
uk with brexit and uh it's an issue that
probably you i i don't want to assume
but you may know less about it than we
do and certainly we would say in this
country that
the same arguments were made these are
stupid racists whatever people but
actually if you speak to a lot of people
who voted this way which we didn't
neither of us did but if you speak to
those people their concerns uh were not
based around ill education or or
whatever but it was
there were some issues that they were
raising that were not being reflected in
the public debate that were dismissed
and
certainly from our perspective it seemed
like there there were some parallels
with the united states so it's not that
people got more stupid or less educated
it's more that their concerns were being
more and more ignored by the left-wing
parties and they were desperate for some
kind of way out which is why they voted
for brexit and which is why they voted
for trump that's absolutely valid and i
have no qualms with that that's what
took place i think the reason i'm has
skeptical to accept that the reason for
trump was
that democrats have abandoned the middle
class
is that more democrats crossed party
lines to vote for john mccain in 2008
than the number that crossed party lines
to vote for trump in 2016
and so
i hesitate to say that that was the
particular reason because the numbers
don't bear it out no i believe it okay
sorry to interrupt but the thing is you
said yourself what trump did and what
brexit did is it brought a lot of
non-voters out of the shadows if you
like so exactly so what actually
happened is these people who stopped
voting for the democrats and for labor
years and years ago because they felt
like these parties stopped representing
them we have a labor party here in the
uk that stopped representing working
people they would argue a long long time
ago and finally a movement came along
that actually represented them so it's
not the mccain democrats we're talking
about here we're talking about people
who are non-voters for decades perhaps
who are now back in the fold because
they're finally seeing someone represent
their views that's the argument
so
that's an empirical question which i
don't have the data in front of me to
say i've not seen any data that suggests
that
20 years inactive democrats are who came
out to vote for trump
took a super specific claim we just
neither one of us really had the backing
to say that
neither of us had the backing to say
that everyone knows non-voters is why
brexit and trump were both surprises
pollsters were polling people who vote
and it was people who don't vote that
swung the results according to britain's
best-known right-wing website the bbc
2.8 million people who had not voted for
decades voted in the brexit referendum
and almost all of them voted for brexit
the same article predicts this could
also happen with trump david's good
faith continues though when we get onto
the issue of trans women in female
prisons i don't lack compassion what i'm
trying to get out with you is do you
envisage circumstances under which it is
right to put a person with a penis in a
female prison
uh i can i can envisage uh theoretical
circumstances where it's the best of the
options that are available yeah i mean
right now there are no third prisons for
trans people and so if you say to me
what is more like i mean like listen
let's just be very up front if you have
if you have a trans woman that is
biologically male and has a penis but is
slight in size and has a very feminine
appearance
by all
statistical likelihood they are far less
likely to assault someone in a women's
prison than they are to be assaulted in
a men's prison and so that's a
particular case where i would say it
makes sense for them to be in a women's
prison yes
okay
see our job as interviewers is to get
david to say what he actually thinks
whether we agree with it or not and when
he explains that he's content to make
vulnerable women share prisons with male
convicts some of whom are sex offenders
as in the case of karen white our job is
done
we don't want to spend any more of your
the audience time trying to win the
argument we've shown you what he thinks
and it's now up to you to decide how you
feel about it but that's not how david
thinks he sees the conversation as a
battle and so when i suggest we move on
to avoid wasting everyone's time he
thinks he's one
we could go we could go around for hours
below
all of a sudden we've spent too much
time on this guys now
we could conclude from this that trying
to speak to different people from all
over the political spectrum is pointless
as david explained people who don't
agree with you are stupid and uneducated
so why engage in good faith but that's
not how we think there are enough people
on youtube talking about how their team
is good and the other team are stupid
and evil we are not like that we think
both teams are stupid and evil and both
have valid points so we'll continue to
have honest conversations in good faith
thank you so much for making that
possible by supporting the show
[Music]
listen i'm very glad he came on the show
i i'm glad we had the conversation that
we did hey dog the p dog he came on he
had some interesting thoughts to say
yeah but also i get the sense that
whenever one of the guys is doing the
asking the other seems kind of like
annoyed that they're even talking to me
foreign